your trademark but the the reason is I
was actually sure how to give a talk or
not and I think on the webpage just well
obvious how to say maybe so I said yes
with a with an F or yes with a but I'm
not sure which one it was that they so I
said yes but decided I say well maybe
I'll give a title maybe not and
organizers were kind enough to I think
realize that I may not be speaking at
all so I put my talk at the end of the
day so if I somehow cancels it will
still be on time but of course these
things have a life of their own
once your name is in the program and
then there is even some TBA you feel
obligated to say some things but I
wasn't sure whether we even talked about
I have some talk prepared but I would
say of something else at the beginning
even if if I don't control journal talk
it's fine it's no big deal
because Warren this morning he explained
polar codes with I think two equations
or one equation and one inequality but I
think that's not quite enough to explain
polar codes I think part of the audience
may not know this and part of audience
may know this but they may want to teach
in their class or something and I think
I have a reasonably clean way to explain
these things perhaps to be teachable in
the undergraduate class or something
that is they're going to do this one it
might perhaps be a useful exercise to go
through that should be hopefully short
if I don't talk myself out of time by
going blah blah blah like this okay so
they have so now the whole structure of
polar codes is depending on a very
simple transformation you start with two
copies of a communication channel which
I'll call to be W this channel is going
to be binary input so this is the
channel and put is some something from
the binary field comes in but the output
can be whatever you want to be the
output alphabet is not particularly that
need to be discrete even and to this one
you apply a very simple transformation
so they either also binary fields
objects you wanna new to you you take
there's modulo to some you send them
over the the first channel and you take
a second one of these use the you to you
send over the second copy of your
channels you say this now this looks
like you haven't done anything at all
right so first of all the things that
you notice is that the u1 u2 isn't
really one to one correspondence but the
child inputs x1 x2 one determines the
other so this transformation is not
redoing anything useful it seems good
however by doing this and by imposing a
decoding order you say I'm gonna look at
the output of this channel y1 y2 I'm
gonna first decode u1 after I done this
I'm going to code you to if you put this
for this constraint what you have done
is to synthesize to synthetic channels
one of the channel which is sitting
between u 1 to y1 y2 from which you're
going to decode the u1 let me call this
channel W - the reason for the minus
sign to be to become obvious shortly and
then of course once you have decoded the
u1 hopefully correctly I've done this
more than once then again don't actually
I apologize don't trust me actually as I
said because the you trust me so now
once you have once you have decoded the
u1 hopefully correctly you're going to
decode the u2 from the up of the channel
which is since you're already code that
you want you have access at the output
to the value of u1 even if it is wrong
I'm going to count your error anyway
already so this we have already made an
error so that doesn't convert me because
the error is a block error I'm going to
worry about the block already happened
so the error event that the estimates
are incorrect is
already counted in these and the first
one comes to you one and then they no
need to consider the possibility ran the
first thing that's punch I'm gonna call
to mean w+ now perhaps i should do a
simple example in here suppose that your
channel was the binary erasure channel
so this y1 y2 are either equal to the
corresponding X's or their erasers let's
take a look at the channels W - okay
now if say this if you get both symbols
correctly you get X 1 and X 2 from which
of course you can figure out what is the
value of u1 is so if there are no
erasers you get then you get your you
one correctly back suppose though if the
first one is erased okay so this that's
y1 which is the X 1 X 1 is erased okay
and you obtain the X 2 well X 2 is u2
very nice but this is completely useless
from the point of view of the you want
so the eurasian the first symbol is an
erasure channel already on the other
hand if the second one is e raised okay
then you obtain you want to figure out
you want but you obtain X 1 X 1 is you
want XOR with a binary conflict it is
equally useless so III Azure is is a
disaster for you the only good thing is
that if both rounds don't erase so this
w - so if W was a b ec of let's say
erasure probability P then W - is a B EC
but they under a sure probability of 1
minus P squared so the razor probability
is 2 P minus P squared at the same time
if you now take a look up what is W plus
you'll figure out for the same argument
at T unless you have both erasers you're
okay okay
the only disaster is both the channels
have to erase because we value you one
for free and so on this helps you a lot
W plus becomes be easy of T squared all
right so you see the following you start
with two copies of a identical channel
with the erasure probability P but what
you are created at the output is
disparity you have created
an equality among the channels even
though on the average they are the same
so these two channels on the average are
good as the original channels they're 10
because the sum of these two numbers
divided by 2 is the same as P yes
because I asked you to because I insist
that you decode the w- channel first ok
so whatever you do you decodable you -
first and then you have the u1 n you in
your hands ok so now we have this now a
few properties of this is the following
so first of all if you compute the the
mutual information developed across W
and the mutual information developed
across w- + w + what you see if you have
some sort of a conservation property
which is this one this is coming from
simply the fact that you had this one
there ok that's the you have done
anything these two channels together are
the same at the two copies of your w so
twice the capacity of w is the same as
the sum of the capacities of W plus you
have conservation of mutual information
and I secondly as we saw here the the
plus channel is better than the usual
added standard original channel which is
in turn better than the W minus channel
and see this one is extremely easy
because of the following take a look at
the channel between the W plus we are
you two here y 1 y 2 u 1 there the
channel there sitting between you two
and Y 2 it's already W so anything else
that you have is is extra stuff so
clearly this inequality that must be
true
in light of this then this must also be
true right that this would otherwise you
would violate the conservation so we
have that ok now second thing second I
cannot count to Christmas Day I can
compute averages but I cannot now if you
took a look at the so this was the
average okay I can also take a look at
the thing with a minus sign I can put
plot plot here W plus minus W minus
divided by 2 I give you the
so this one we know if I put a plus sign
here you get IW itself and you put here
they IW like that okay so now if you
take a look at the erasure case okay the
difference divided by two is simply P
times 1 minus P D so this will be the
plot so the the iw is 1 minus P you're
plotting 1 minus P versus P times 1
minus P you'll get this this kind of a
curve for 0 to 1 this is for the erasure
channel case in fact this kind of plot
is true for any channel that you want to
so no matter what W starts it from ok
but you're going to have is the
following in fact the erasure is the
most despising if you wish good every
channel here is lying somewhere in
between no matter what W that you start
with if you plotted the I W on the
capacity of the channel W in the x-axis
and the difference or the capacity of
the good and the bad channels on the y
axis divided by 2
you'll get a plot like this one
everything is inside here the proof of
this is is a simple consequence of the
what the information to is called the
misses Gerber's lemma the it's a simple
thing to prove okay and the name is says
Gerber and I longer stalk I'll give you
a story but mrs. burgers a mess that's a
different program that's it alright so
let me call this lower line let me give
that name let me call this thing since
it's lower lambda okay let me call this
thing to be
so you have this lower bound lambda okay
let me call this lambda epsilon I don't
know why I'm calling this this thing to
be epsilon let me also define a quantity
which is very little space but they can
you see this from the back maybe not
yes no not from the camera that's for
sure all right so that can't do it here
and this let me call Kappa Epsilon to be
the minimum of lambda epsilon and over 1
minus Epsilon okay this is saying that
so first of all if you put here epsilon
1 minus epsilon there okay so if you
take channels which are moderates
they're neither very bad in terms of
capacity nor very good in terms of
capacity if your channel lives somewhere
in here if you're ordering mission
information and somewhere in there okay
then this is saying that this you'll
create disparity at least by this amount
kappa this is the best thing that you
will be creating this parity at least by
that much okay fair enough so now now
that we know all these properties of the
single polarization step let's see what
I can are gonna repeat this process
repeatedly I guess repetition Oh repeat
this process multiple times so you start
from channel W okay you can now create
this you created these two channels
nothing prevents me from applying the
same transformation to to these things
so what we're gonna create is that the
the plus of the W plus and minus or the
W plus plus or the W minus and that's
all so forth alright so now yeah this
now this
going off diagram like like this
I can't compute on this and this object
a few statistics okay so here's what I
will well compute here I'm going to take
the following say can I take a look at a
particular column there are these four
channels here for each of these channels
I'm going to take a look at their mutual
informations this eye of these channels
okay and compute their numerical average
arithmetic average of these these four
numbers there let me call these numbers
to be mu okay
I started musi row which is this is
equal to the eye of the original W okay
I have mu one which is the average of
the mutual informations of this of
course because of this statement here mu
1 is nothing but mu 0 for the same
reason u 2 is nothing but mu 1 so this
is the constant line is a very
uninteresting computation so I only
obtain a sequence of constants okay fine
okay
all right the second thing I will do is
to do the following thing this is the
first moment if you wish all these of
these columns I'm going to computer
second moments why not now let me show
them to be news okay so this star space
iow squared okay and then on the Sun
this column I am nu 1 nu 2 nu 3 etc
right so now what can you say about
these about these news so now these
let's take a look at this thing once
more home anything about the what do you
Reese I guess I can use this one for
sisterly safe at this moment
following factors obvious if I take the
average of squares is bigger than the
square of the average in fact it is
bigger exactly by the amount which is
the this half difference squared is a
quality right so it is bigger than this
by exactly this this particular thing
there so now if you take a look at the
iw+ on iw-
their averages is IW consequently they
this average square is bigger than this
one so you have this for free this is
like that so for the same reason this
thing propagates so every step creates a
second moment and of course these
numbers by the way they're for bounded
by one because all these mutual
informations that I'm computing are
provide one bit so I'm taking averages
of numbers between 0 and 1 so these eyes
these news are increasing sequence upper
bounded by one at the same time
let me have a compute of 3rd statistics
let me call it the something else any
suggestions for this this is Rob uses
lemma see they've got a Sigma okay
it's only following so this Sigma is
going to be the following
so Sigma I Sigma n if you wish is the
fraction of moderate channels the
fraction of these channels that are in
this column okay which happened to a
mutual information between epsilon 1
minus epsilon these haven't become
neither good nor bad fraction of let's
say epsilon moderate so they I count how
many channels in this cut in this
particular column have mutual
information still in this interval okay
oh and I've eyed by total number of
channels that you have in this column I
call this DVD Sigma so what you see is
the following so the first thing that we
observe is that this if you take a look
at how much is just you an increase I
just put down this inequality signs to
these news you'll see the following
thing this new Memphis one is bigger
than nu n okay by at least this Kappa
Epsilon times times Sigma because each
of these in moderate channels so each of
these moderate channels is going to
contribute at least this copper absolute
amount of disparity disparity to the
dude into the variance okay so we have
this inequality they're very good so now
essentially we're done now to see the
following this these news are increasing
sequence but which is bounded
consequently they converge they were
limits okay
in particular difference between mu n
plus 1 and you end this thing goes to 0
but this guy is an upper bound to the
diffraction of a moderate channel
moderate channels okay if I divide this
thing by epsilon squared okay it's just
a constant depends only on epsilon but
not on n okay this top guy is going to 0
as n goes to infinity consequently Sigma
n converges to 0 so this process of
doing this doing this operation you'll
end up is no moderate channels will
survive this process
the the large column you're only going
to find channels which are either
neutral information very close to one or
mutually from very close to zero and the
and the first one here saying that you
actually preserve mutual information
each peach column means that the
diffraction of these good channels the
ones which have mutual information close
to one must be that exactly equal to iw
because there other ones are are all
zero so this one says yes polarization
happens okay and the polarization
creates the correct number of good and
bad channels the number of good trend
that we get is exactly the capacitor so
that we started from and if you should
build a communication system a code out
of this you will simply put information
through the good chance that we created
and you will send no data over the over
the the bad channels okay all right so
that's perhaps for the information to
risk or interest among you this might be
a song that you connect to teach in a
class within forever altered time for a
for something without going into
martingales blah blah so on okay you
only have pulled out two misses Gerber's
lemma out of your hat but that's
something that people had to prove
anyway at some moment and these in these
courses but is not a okay so now I think
I'm okay with what I wanted to sort of
say for this particular thing proof is
necessary in the following way the
marketing get proof what I said okay let
me now walk make a random walk in this
tree I just go up or down and so on so
forth like this one this is a bounded
Martinez must act must converge okay
since that converges you must have a
subsequent two things to be to be the
same but because of this they cannot be
the same unless you're converting to
here or here so I'm essentially here but
you require this martingale in a very
naive way okay because the the
martingale proof says that you have a
convergent sequence this is only thing
I'm using a sequence which is simply
successive things which go to 0 which is
much weaker than a convergent statements
right so I'm even the order of
martingale proof the martingale Ness was
using a very weak way
so essentially hence I can discard the
martingale business have used something
which is much much weaker by also that
it converges as a multi random variables
because the new n goes to zero then that
gives that well to prove a sequence
converging is not sufficiently pure
successive thing terms come come close
to each other at that is I mean
convergence so if we want to to state in
this terms is exactly the orthogonal
increments process has to have blah blah
okay so now now that I've sort of done
just this true to this stuff should I
talk about something else how much time
do I have
yeah this states something so that I'll
say something it should be fine okay
I'll skip million slides okay no I'm not
negotiating this a day I don't need to
actually talk at all honestly but it's
also something which I'm not even
talking perhaps myself the note the
parentheses here maybe I should actually
highlight them nothing yes it's very
important these parentheses when I first
read financial reports in American
newspapers I was completely confused by
these parentheses
they're probably negative numbers and as
they answer sir
so I'm a negative water here the perhaps
not completely negative because the
there were some certain hundred topics
in which I was indeed negative waters so
ii know this is wrong and so on so forth
and then but in this case maybe i'm
simply a sort of neutral persons as I
just put brackets but the work is
actually mostly over a guy who's a PhD
pseudo mind sort of midway in his inner
stuff and he got interested by himself
on whole bunch of interests poems that I
barely understand myself but the let me
skip all this business for the polar
codes but just to say that the I want to
replace this plus sign which were used
heavily in two places one of them us to
show that this transformation u1 u2 x
one x two was one to one that required
this a motorboat to operation to have
certain properties and second was mrs.
Gerber's lemma which was heavier on the
fact that there was a plus in between
yet to talk about the this plus business
here so I would replace this plus with
the star for a binary case you can't do
anything per se it's modular
complementation soft stuff you cannot do
anything but the for for larger
alphabets you can think of which
operations that we can do Aaron had
worked on these things for a while and
first of all if the input of a bet is a
prime cardinality then you can turn it
into a simple abelian group by a modulo
addition no I guess that that would work
that will polarize other stuff internal
abelian groups you get something called
multi-level polarization named
depolarization not too extreme no
channels perfectly good or perfectly bad
but also things which are halfway in
between but still easy all right so now
the things also work if you have nitrous
group structures but quasi group
structures meaning that they you have
both left and right invertibility
but no neutral elements anything of this
type okay so so here's an example okay
you have the star operation x1 times x2
gives you this table it is not a group
but is a quasi group this thing
polarizes okay all right
Iran had this very nice example in his
sinister
is one certain very simple classical
operation which polarized every channel
he proved that one now the thing is for
quasi groups in general date they always
polarize you know that - ok so now what
you end up having to do to general all
the stuff is to talk a look at
partitions ok so you take a partition of
the input off of it ok and then we
define some strange operation saying
that the I take a look at the element
files operations within the partition
classes so let me define this multiply
doing this star operation on to
partition elements I really find
something called a stable partition if
things begin to repeat ok so here are
some examples of stable partitioning
especially if you do 0 1 and the at the
0 1 ok then the star operation gives you
0 & 3 because you're gonna 0 1 gives you
this if you to 0 1 cross 2 3 you get
things that are here so 1 2 and then you
see that the other ones also still the
same so this is a and the next step is
going to give you back so this H is a
stable partition because polarization
stuff okay
okay so now you need a uniformity
preserving this inverter ability of u 1
u 2 to X 1 X 2 the sort of obvious you
clearly need this otherwise nothing will
happen and now you need some notion of n
Calissa T type notions to make sure that
deploys and does happen you sufficiently
mix things together otherwise things
don't work well so you say that the you
can connect a element of X with
operation star to some other element of
X ok if you can find some multiplication
on the right which will take the X you
multiply not that multiplier you end up
in the leg in the Y so for example here
there's a small diagram as to who can
you reach from whom this is 0 1 2 3
called all these diagrams it's a cyclic
order starting from 0 1 2 & 3
now irreducibility for example this one
is that you do so because you go back
and forth okay you cannot reach
everywhere if you loosen that you can
reach everything for everything so you
can start with whatever 0 and then you
can buy sufficiently nice things you can
reach all these other things but this
one for example reduce about periodic
from 0 in even steps you can only go to
one and three and only in all steps you
can come back to 2 0 and 2 and vice
versa ok now our goal is that it means
that you are no periodicity namely some
some else it will connect in L steps
everything to everything and exactly all
steps
that's we go to city and now this is
necessary a good asset if you don't have
regular city you won't have polarization
the first of this might be sufficient
kind at yeah ok this should be in fact a
sufficient condition to okay but it
turns out no because you see a curiosity
is hiding too much of the actual
structure of the group because this
diagram here you can decide about this
just by looking at this thing here but
this diagram hides by what
multiplication did you go from A to B
Fitness you don't know you just simply
went but you don't know why with model
[ __ ] elements that's important so this
is not sufficient you need something
called stronger Garissa T which I'll
skip all the details of okay
well if you say that the this stronger
Garissa tea is in fact this is
sufficient condition for the operation
repolarizing in fact the portion itself
but the left inverse of this operation
should be strongly ergodic which is
checkable easily then if if and only if
the operation star is is polarizing so
with this I think I will stop I
apologize for giving I mean one should
only have one topic in the in a talk
it's all semi cardinal principle I seem
to have I hit this one but I hope there
at least two one I think the first part
probably went through the second part
might be a slight disaster but so I'll
stop anyway thanks
okay so sorry say see poor yes would you
find so dizzy for you some I apologize
skip the whole bunch of details which
was actually important the the so they
of course on g4 we can come up with for
any alphabet you can find a quasi group
so it's not a problem of so given a up
of it X can you find operation polarizes
the answer is yes okay so for any
alphabet you can count a quasi group for
example which are polarized but you can
check if any particular operation both
polarizer or not only the formal I think
of addition modulo four okay
that'll polarize okay but not to the
usual return polarization as to 0 or to
two bits there also be channels which
are one bit capacity but there are also
very easy channels those channels are
also easy to decode so this polarization
is a slightly more general phenomenon
talking about in the polarization not to
purely extremal channels but also to
easy channels from which the output is
easily decodable essentially that blocks
and one codes are are good enough
channels yes the neutral polarization is
slightly different
well it's the same for the binary case
with some it's not clip it's different
or not yes that's exactly yes
we don't have sufficient mixing among
these different symbols then you could
essentially to each of these necessary
conditions they're necessary because
they're counter examples you can come up
with the polar operation which is not a
gothic and then you can kinda channel
this channel will not be polarized under
you give me an opportunity I could come
to the channel for which when you do
this operation on it the W my w+ are in
fact exactly the same as W itself okay
it's so you get this it's essentially a
process get stuck
okay this w it's not just that a mutual
information as that move the channel
does not move okay you end up with to
Childish are completely causality you
started from
so no hope of ever producing anything